It is even better than it was pitched
and it is even more complicated
and fun and interesting and playful than i could
have ever imagined this job being i got a call
from kevin saying can you come in and see me
at marvel and i went oh i'm getting the can no
we're done i'm getting i'm getting a can and
he's going to be nice and and generous and
sweet about it but i i'm and then he pitched this
totally bonkers um tv show i've always been hungry
to lean into the comic book stories that we're
leaning into in this show and i didn't know if
i'd have the opportunity to explore it which
is the reason why i wanted to be a part of
the avengers to begin with when joss
asked me to he said look at these comics
and tell me if you are interested and those
specific comics are the ones that feige said
this is what our show is going
to be about for Wandavision
wanda and vision aren't we a fine pair this
is our home now i want us to fit in oh this is
gonna be a gap our content is so different than
marvel um it's like a conversation of american
sitcom through the decades with a marvel film and
they're constantly in dialogue with one another
so it's been it's been really fun and different
where did you two move from how long have you been
married and why don't you have children yet our
story i think what my wife means to say is that
we moved for move from where married when damn it
why oh arthur stop it stop it stop it stop it i
really loved filming the 70s specifically because
of the content yeah um it was like the most
lucy i went in this in this series it was actually
the only time matt shakman told me i was too much
am i dead no why would you
think that because you are
i think the thing that i've loved most about
working with paul specifically in this situation
is even though paul was painted red and in other
movies and we've had to do really ridiculous
things in reality of like uh blowing up something
in his head while there is a josh brolin and
a onesie with a hockey glove on like there's a
lot of crazy imaginative things we've had to do
together but i think paul and i we both have these
inner children that met on this show that's right
it's been fun sitcoms are fun
we are an unusual couple you know oh i don't think
that was ever in question i'm so excited now that
we've cracked open this other part of her so that
there hopefully could be more stories to tell
and what i love about the show is as mad as
that trailer that i'm sure you've seen is it's
it's actually a really elegantly put together
puzzle piece um i think you know when when
everything as bonkers as it looks everything will
make sense welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new Wandavision x-men avengers
video marvel just posted this big preview so we'll
break it down and explain what they said about the
x-men of it all and how this is crossing over with
doctor strange too if you're new to the channel
we're doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
let me know everything you want them to do with
x-men during marvel phase 4. starting with the
big stuff first they're doing new backstory
in the episodes for scarlet witch and elizabeth
olsen obviously talking about all the most famous
scarlet witch x-men comics that they're finally
doing on the show like house of m some of you
may remember that a couple years ago during the
avengers infinity war premiere she said that she
would love to do a house of m storyline at some
point but that was probably before kevin feige
gave her the call that they were gonna do that
story on Wandavision they even focus on that house
of m wine bottle in the trailer for a good couple
seconds meson du mapree means house of contempt
house of m as you see the m on the wine bottle but
they will also be doing more history for her more
backstory before avengers age of ultron getting
her powers and quicksilver getting his powers with
the mind stone what her life in sokovia was like
and further back as a way to help sort of recon or
fold in all the x-men character history from the
comics this is where you get to questions like
how can magneto be her father if her parents were
killed by iron man stark tech weaponry and sokovia
that was their whole motivation in avengers age of
ultron the reason why they were working with baron
von strucker we hate tony stark and the avengers
even though he doesn't appear with them during
this footage kevin feige was there with them doing
this same interview talking about the series he's
already implied that they're kind of retconning
scarlet witch as a mutant in the mcu even though
they've implied that before and there's been some
tie-in canonical books that have described her as
a mutant but they had the rights issue with fox
so that was the big reason why you've never heard
anyone say the word mutant in an mcu film at least
so far obviously that's different now because they
can do whatever they want they have all the
x-men characters back the way that kevin feige
also talked about her during the series is that
we'll find out the full extent of her powers and
why she's called the scarlet witch in the comics
that implies larger chaos magic which obviously
gets into big doctor strange doctor strange two
stuff i'll talk about that in a second as well
because during this interview kevin feige was
also hyping up how they're using the series to
directly set up doctor strange 2 and cross over
with it but a lot of you eagle-eyed viewers have
also spotted some larger marvel phase 4 easter
eggs in terms of new x-men and fantastic four
crossover characters and connections that they've
been setting up and some of those will also help
explain some of these retcons and the way they
fold in the x-men characters it'll happen in a
number of different ways there won't be one
blanket explainer for x-men in the mcu right
now the way that kevin feige talks about it is
he just refers to them all as mutants so there
are a lot of different kinds of mutants then you
have your core x-men characters so when you're
talking about x-men characters you're typically
talking about the biggest ones like professor x
magneto wolverine cyclops storm all the core
x-men team members muse is just a broader blanket
term that you can use to talk about deadpool in
conjunction with all this too he's a good example
of a character who's a mutant but not necessarily
an x-men character in the traditional sense
the other really cool thing that elizabeth olsen
reveals during this is doing more scarlet witch
movies in Wandavision potentially in the future
after this she says oWandavision season 1 opens
up the possibility of new stories set after the
events of the series and obviously that includes
the events of doctor strange too multiverse
of madness but she's also talking about other
stories beyond that the way that kevin feige
initially pitched Wandavision he made it sound
like it was only going to be one season but they
were using it to set up all this big marvel phase
four multiverse stuff and practically kind of
learn how to make the shows the way they make
the movies behind the scenes but now it sounds
like elizabeth olsen is actually jazzed to come
back as scarlet witch in other movies and cross
over so i think obviously that means avengers 5
because she's already one of the most powerful
characters in the mcu right now before the events
of Wandavision and if she's going to get a big
power upgrade with her chaos magic during the
events of the series then think about how powerful
she's going to be by the time we get to avengers 5
and you have all the connections to the new x-men
movies if you're using her at the beginning of
marvel phase 4 to set up the concept of mutants in
the mcu wouldn't you also then bring her back for
cameos in some of those mutant based movies like
the rebooted x-men mcu movies there were a couple
new scenes that they dropped during that preview
most of them from the black and white episode the
way they talk about it i'm assuming that's just
Wandavision episode one the 1950s looking one
they said that they only filmed one episode in
front of a live studio audience like the dick
van dyke series they filmed it with old school tv
cameras and technology like they used back during
the day as well they said because of the way
the cameras worked they actually had to paint
paul bettany blue so there was a blue version of
vision walking around the set when they were doing
the black and white stuff the showrunner said that
they were going for dick van dyke show references
bewitched obviously like we see during the trailer
i think most people picked up on the bewitched
references father knows best the partridge family
just amongst many many other sitcoms that they
were referencing i laughed so hard when i saw
this picture of vision and scarlet witch in the
twin beds this is a dick van dyke reference but
the fact you zoom in enhance on vision here he's
got his full avengers costume on all the makeup
everything even the mind stone in his forehead
but he's got that funny looking sleep mask over
his eyes when kevin feige was hyping up the doctor
strange 2 crossover the really interesting thing
i think a lot of people haven't talked about yet
is the title multiverse of madness so the term
madness obviously implies things are going to be
really chaotic and scarlet witch is going to play
a role in setting that off but if they're going
for so many house of m easter eggs and her losing
her mind going mad so to speak madness in the
title is also a reference to her own psychological
state her madness when she went full house of m so
don't be surprised if they end Wandavision
on some crazy cliffhanger house of m style
moment but everyone post all your theories in the
comments they keep reiterating that they're gonna
try and drop the series before the end of the year
but no definitive release date yet just because
they're still racing through post-production they
finished filming last week so hopefully at some
point before thanksgiving they'll release the
next Wandavision trailer and then they'll just
put the release date in that trailer my brand
new mandalorian season 2 episode 3 video will
post on friday just like normal so while you wait
for everything click here to re-watch that crazy
Wandavision trailer with all the x-men easter eggs
and click here for my brand new mandalorian season
2 episode 2 video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!